Google Cloud updates join us digitally
for the Google data cloud and AI Summit
on Wednesday March 29th where you can
learn from the top Minds in data and AI
discover new ways to thrive in a
changing world and engage with new
Solutions register today for the no cost
event our teams at Google Cloud have
their eye on the future as we evolve our
strategies to protect technology Choice
simplify data integration increase AI
adoption deliver needed information on
demand and meet security requirements
check out the 2023 data and AI Trends
report for tips customer examples and
metrics-rich research behind the top
five Global Trends make data work for
you is our new ebook with ways to make
money from things you already have like
your data and AI from improving supply
chain inefficiencies to speeding up a
document-based workflow there's going to
be something for you so check it out in
the links below thanks for watch